qu'est-ce que tu fais
arnaque pour dire bonjour bonjour George Bamberger
Serena Shaw Je pense que nous devrions être mariés
Je n'ai jamais pensé que je te trouverais Je n'aurais jamais
pensé que je trouverais quelqu'un combien est à
toi
J'aimerais bien savoir ce que tu penses
de notre  petite aberration je pense que vous avez
mis neuf mois pour faire environ six mois de
travail pouvez-vous trouver une femme ou un partenaire
bien
j'ai bien peur que vos stocks ne soient plus
une garantie suffisante une future chose
dont nous avons parlé nous la perdrons nous
promettons de  se dire tout je
ne voulais pas t'effrayer je ne suis pas ce
genre de femme ils ne sont plus pareils
la seule chose qui a changé c'est toi
j'oublie tout boueux John
tu as un fils tu mens
j'aimerais  parle à ta femme il y a eu un
meurtre hier soir
tu dois t'éloigner de ces
melons tu ne peux
pas il t'a trahi
tout ce que tu as fait tu as fait pour nous
je ne peux pas te perdre